[Musik]
so jetzt jetzt ist wirklich endgültig
erreicht wo ich wirklich mal einen stopp
setzen muss ok herzlich kommt sogar von
kanal zu wir müssen es heute eine der
schwersten aufgaben stellen die wir
jemals in der geschichte dieses kanals
erlebt haben und zwar habe ich ja vor
ich glaube vier tagen hat es
mittlerweile einen wie hoch dann eben
den ich auf ein hilf mir video reagiert
habe dieses hilft mir video war dass von
diesem jungen der auf lebensmittel steht
und es tut mir leid euch sagen zu müssen
dass es davon einen zweiten teil gibt
dem wir uns heute anschauen werden das
geht überhaupt nicht einige von euch
haben sich gewünscht an diese leute geht
an dieser stelle die frage raus was ist
verkehrt mit euch und wir starten
[Musik]
leute das ist ja dass dieser
tatverdächtiger den haben wir noch
leider sehr schmerzlich in der rede
plätzen wie ihr euch zumindest die
gesagt hätten festgestellt dass sich
dadurch dass er wirklich eine
atemberaubende frisur hat wir checken
dass an der stelle noch mal ab heute der
hat den frisurentrends 2021 schon
vorausgeahnt und die frisur nach der
krise die hatte schon drauf er sei
einfach tomaten titten lacht ihr egal
das war gar keinen job hat ist einfach
tomaten tippen dinge
das sieht ja aus wie kraut und rüben
da befreien wir die planung und er ist
sich keiner schuld bewusst
leider ja klasse aus der wäsche schaut
könnte der deutsche profi das scheint
schon ganz schön zu mögen
ich habe ein auge auf die er hat ein
auge auf ihn auf ihm nicht auf ihnen
leute hat nicht ein auge auf ihn und er
achtet auf ihn ein
er hat einst seine augen auf ihn oben
drauf los
ok ja gut du bist bist du schon bewusst
was aber gerade vor dass du bist hier
bewusst was du dir gerade anschaut ja es
ist ein laib käse
okay es ist ein wagenrad aus einem
milchprodukt an irgendeiner art und
weise verarbeitet der grunde keine
ahnung wichtiger das kam aus la cour aus
dass der käse für versagen oder der
alltagssituation für uns alle war leider
schon an dem punkt wo wir einfach wow da
gesehen haben wirklich einfach nur
gelbes wagenrad uns gedacht haben geile
sau alter
[Musik]
also alles klar gut scheinbar hat er
noch kontakt zu dieser jungen frauen
also die haben wir die letzte folge auch
schon besprochen teil der ist mir
wirklich augenscheinlich aufgefallen
dass sie die im augenbrauen von angry
birds hat von dem gelben drei
gegenstimmen schnellen vogel von angry
birds müsste der mann so schießen kann
[Gelächter]
die denken sich scheinbar noch okay
vielleicht haben sich zwei gefunden
ja ja ja fast vergessen der kleine
schillinge hat natürlich noch die salate
unter dem kopfkissen ist ja klar leitern
also für bedingungen den beruhigenden
schlaf dem man das natürlich brauchen
muss ein fleisch produkt unter dem
kopfkissen liegen
wie sie einfach mit keinem wort darauf
einging
was es mit ihr älter du bist gerade weil
zum ersten mal mit einem date zu hause
du findest eine salami wohlgemerkt kein
salatic holt muss man im kopf gehabt
wohlgemerkt kein salami stick okay wir
reden hier wirklich über 60 zentimeter
also ultra vetter auch schon von so
einer salami und schinken eier für den
kleinen hunger
ja aber die anderen keine salami und dem
kopf in einem kopfkissen hatten
das ist der unterschied die noch die
sachen haben stehen ganz falsche
richtung
was hat sich da vor ort gesagt du bist
nicht so ein draufgänger der auf
hungerhaken steht es ist ein ding
es ist ein ding war meiner gibt zwei
sorten von männern es gibt die sensible
und es gibt die draufgänger die auf
hungerhaken stehen ok ok stellt keine
farbe hat das wird schon wirtschaftlich
wird schon recht haben durch das
richtige frauen
tigermutter leute ich habe gerade mal
ich hab kann sich wahrscheinlich nicht
mal zeigen in diesem video das geht
nicht habe weitergespielt und die machen
nur so viel rum jetzt gerade in dieser
folge auf youtube aber sowohl somit wohl
real tag das habe ich schon so auch
provokanten titel geschrieben aber ich
glaube das darf eigentlich nicht auf
youtube sein
[Musik]
er hätte ja was für ein kellner ist dass
der leiter bekommt ihr mit über mir die
stimmung umschlägt möglichst gerade eben
so einfach komplett happy guter job noch
zu so what the hell haben die da schon
wieder gemacht
hier können wir dieser irgendwann new
york das sei aber das können wir ganz
platzieren oder ingame vorbereitet hier
muss aber dazu sagen leute auf die
gefallen dass er mich jetzt verurteilt
kräuterbutter ist eine sache war
da werde ich auch zum lauten also potter
wird da bin ich wirklich ein großer fan
von steak beckert beste leben aber das
will sich die wahrscheinlich jetzt in
die ohren schmieren oder sowas
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo wir dann wäre das verdient also
müssen wir sagen diese folge ist selbst
für rtl2 verhältnis einfach unterirdisch
jetzt sitzt die frau dort halbnackt
bewaffnet mit der salami wirklich mit
diesem fund von salami so ein teil auf
dem bett und machte auch noch auf warum
weiß kein schwein momente in denen man
wirklich an der menschheit zweifel
[Musik]
warum sollte ich weiß ich weiß nicht
welcher nur die kräuterbutter in der
hose lege ich muss wirklich sagen diese
vier grad selbst für hilfen wir
verhältnisse wirklich krank viele
dislike ja ich glaube wir verstehen so
langsam warum so jetzt jetzt ist
wirklich endgültig wo ich wirklich mal
einen stopp setzen muss okay ich musste
das geht nicht
das können wir nicht machen ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich weiß ja nicht was euch
gerade zeigen konnte oder ob ich das
ruhig bleiben muss
also springt jetzt quasi zu ihr in die
kiste man hat einfach ein bisschen
kräuterbutter auf die alte drauf
[Musik]
nee nee da trägt sie wirklich alles um
das gibt es nicht
die leute frage an euch kennt einer eine
von diesen personen dass diese helfen
erfolge
das würde mich wirklich mal etwas wir
mit denen zu reden und da mal
rauszufinden wieso wieso habt ihr es
getan
der ob an der stelle waren deckel drauf
leute kriegt hier drüben ein völlig
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnt
ihr mann klar abonnieren und von mir
bekommt jetzt ein versprechen das mir so
eine art von häfen video nicht mehr
anfangen wäre das das da ist wirklich
die ganze wahl haben